hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and there's one
thing
that really gets me excited and that is
answering your
property investment questions so if you
comment below
literally any question about property
investing
i will do my best to answer your
property investment questions so start
commenting below
i've been investing now for 12 years
i've done over 300 property deals
and i'll be happy to answer your
property investment questions
do me a favor though smash the like
button also subscribe
turn the notification bell on and i'm
going to start answering questions
right this second abdullah
he said hi samuel how do you determine
the end value of
the house in a brr deal so
first thing is i look at comparables on
right move house prices and just see
what selling
are like for like house yourself that
will give you a bit of a rough idea
secondly i'd speak to a local estate
agents in the area and ask them
what will this house be worth once it's
done up what will the end value be
and the third thing you can do is you
can get an actual valuer
to go out to the property and tell you
what the value will be and just explain
to them what spec the house is going to
be at and they will give you a gdv
gross development value which will give
you a very accurate
amount of the end value about what else
we got
sachin patel hi samuel when starting out
did you decide on the size of the
portfolio or so how did you decide on
the size of the portfolio you're walking
towards
i'm sure this would have changed over
time but right at the start was that
thought
out or goal um so certainly to begin
with when i started out
my goal was just to get one house i was
just like i just want to get a house i
want to get that feeling i get in the
keys
and then when i got my first house i
refinanced it and pulled the money back
out and i thought great i'm going to do
that again and you know times changed i
went through the
the pretty big recession um which
happened around about 2008 2009 i bought
my first house just before properties
really started crashing in birmingham
and then as time went on i started
building my portfolio i just
i had a goal i wanted to have a thousand
houses and it was actually my good
friend and mentor
lord sugar who um sat down with me and
actually told me that my business plan
was bad
he told me that you know why would you
want a thousand houses
and i really changed my business plan
and i realized that a big deal and a
small deal the same amount of effort
just like selling off my small deals and
putting them into bigger development
projects
um so now it's not about for me it's not
about how many properties i'm involved
with how many deals i'm doing
it's more about profit how much money am
i making
so um yeah it's changed and it will
change over time for you as well
but that's kind of how it worked out for
me but to start with and just say
get yourself financially free how many
properties do you need to be
to be able to retire hit do that first
and then you can start playing and
growing and scaling hope that helps
jordan griffith says i have found a one
bed flat where i can knock down the
kitchen wall and split the living room
to make it a two bed
i was wondering what the process is to
do this and how would i need planning
permission
uh jordan you shouldn't need planning
permission to turn a one bed flat into a
two bed flat
especially if you're just if you're if
you're turning effectively you're
turning one room into another room
you're turning a big kitchen and you're
knocking it down and you're
turning just space like living area
sitting room i mean i always said to
turn a sitting room into a bedroom you
just put a bed in it you don't need
plenty permission to do that
but if you're ever unsure speak to a
local council but no you shouldn't need
planning permission to do that
chantal if i wanted to buy my council
flat for a discount could i take out the
equity straight away
and invest in a second property um good
question
so chantal if you are buying
a council property at a discount i
assume you're talking about the
right to buy scheme which is very
different from the help to buy scheme
very different from shared ownership
you can't sell the property for five
years
lest you have to pay back the council
part of the discount that you bought and
it's like a slating
sliding scale if you want to refinance
the property
i don't think there's any rules to stop
you doing that but that i imagine that
many lenders you might struggle
i'd probably speak to a mortgage advisor
about that and see what the options are
but it sounds like a great plan to me if
you can do it so
good luck all right artist flows i've
bought my first
flat as a buy to let best thing to do
next waiting for a deposit again is
going to take me one to two years
the slow way to build your portfolio is
to work hard
save deposits and buy that is the slow
way
you can speed things up by applying
different strategies like lease option
agreements
which is where you buy a property now
but pay for it later and then you're
just gonna pay a very small
as little as a one pound option fee of
course you'll have to pay your legal
fees as well
so you can do creative things like that
you can do joint ventures
start finding some better juicier deals
and asking investors to put the money in
um i would suggest doing that rather
than doing it the slow way one hundred
percent
oh hey hi sammy first of all say thank
you for your time videos you're so
welcome
by the way if you like my videos do me a
massive favor smash the like button
also i'm looking forward to reading your
comments as well so comment your
questions i'll be answering them real
soon
um my partner and i've just bought our
first house in london for 400 000 pounds
we've put
a 60 000 pounds deposit i just wanted to
ask approximately how much
equity can i release after five years
and do you think we should wait for five
years
or remortgage after two year fixed
interest term i look forward to reply
listen after two years if the house has
gone up in value and you've got equity
i'd really straight away
well i don't know why you've got this
five year thing in your head
what's five years got to do with
anything if you've got two year fixed
mortgage term and after two years
there's equity to be released then
refinance and pull out as much equity as
you can and then
reinvest it for sure i'll do as soon as
you can
colin grant about to purchase my first
buy to let all from listening to you
congratulations good job i'm in
birmingham
and not too happy with my solicitor can
you recommend a solicitor to use for my
next purchase colin the problem is if i
recommend you my solicitor on youtube
every single person is going to use that
solicitor and then you're not going to
be happy with that solicit because it'll
be too slow because everyone's using him
um in all seriousness solicitors do tend
to be
a bit slow i don't know why you're not
happy my suggestion would be probably to
speak to a property investor such as me
but probably not on youtube i have to be
careful endorsing people
um yeah i just just asked for a
recommendation it's really important
that you've got a good power team you
know you solicit your account and your
mortgage broker you're letting agent
your estate agents your builders all
these people are really good
so um yeah try asking around sorry i
can't help you more than that
maybe join samuel 365 and then we'll
have a conversation i'll hook you with
my team
until then sergio elle uh hi samuel i
still got a mortgage can i move my flat
from a personal residential
to my limited company and refinances buy
to let how much is it going to cost me
um so you can do that but it's going to
it's going to be such a pain in the neck
i've got a lot of houses in my personal
name i've sold
some of them but i i sat down with my
accountant and we worked out how much is
it going gonna cost to transfer
them from my personal name to my company
and unfortunately the only way to do it
is to literally sell them
to yourself you cannot just switch them
over easily it's a nightmare and you're
gonna obviously have to pay
stamp duty tax and all kinds of stuff so
i would advise
maybe consider just leaving it in your
personal name
but speak to an accountant abdullah
aftab
samuel bro all the training packages you
offer are
online or i have to come out at your
academy because i live outside the uk
um no yeah they're all online all of my
training is online
i am running events as well so we have
the physical events
but we also have online versions as well
so you can check it out on the website
i'll leave all the details in the
description below
peter pavlak do you think non-standard
construction properties are a good
investment um
not really no because you're going to
really struggle to get you might
have a good return on investment or not
even you won't because you can't get
lending on them
you might have a good yield but you're
going to really struggle to get a good
return on investment because
financing options on most non-standard
construction properties are really bad
and even if you manage to get it you're
going to struggle to sell it if you ever
want to sell it
so generally speaking be careful i'm not
saying always no
but be careful with non-standard
construction which means by the way
it's just built not the traditional
standard brick way
it's you know and you can usually tell
by looking if an estate agent is selling
a non-standard construction property
they should have to put it in the
description so you can see if not
it's going to come up in your legal pack
your broker's going to tell you pretty
quickly when the lender's unhappy but
yeah i'd probably say be careful
sm hi samuel i'm looking to buy bm
a bmv below market value that is four
bed hmo in
article four area the seller does not
have copies of tenancy agreements to
prove hmo status before article 4 came
into force
but the property was entered into and
declared as a 4-bit hmo in a register
kept by the council before article 4.
i've seen the proof of this in the
register would you proceed on this basis
so sm basically if the council are happy
it's okay
so we've as as you've said with a uh
it's below market value that's great
with a hmo property in article 4 area
i've had situations where i've been i've
been buying uh i've bought a property
and i've had to turn into a hmo and i've
had a very limited time frame to do that
because article 4 is about to come in
and i've asked the councillors actually
wolverhampton council i said what do i
need
to get the grandfather right to prove
that this was used as a hmo
prior to article 4 coming in and they
said literally if i've just got fire
doors in the property and stuff and i
can show evidence of that that would be
good for them
so i think each council's probably
operates slightly differently
but if the council are happy and they've
said yep we've got proof and and it's
written down
you should be fine so you know but as i
say check with the council
uh and they all work slightly
differently all right last question
i want you to comment below as well
because i'll answer your questions next
week this is um
lornas mike leonis
hi samuel buying non-habitable property
do you have to pay
stamp duty the answer to that is no
you don't pay stamp duty if the property
is not habitable
i'm in the process of buying a house
which i'll turn into a hmo once it's
fixed up
also i'm thinking to buy a rundown house
for myself
and then switch to residential mortgage
once it's done up do you think it's
possible
yeah sure um i mean if you buy if you're
moving into it yourself
and you're fixing up you could sell it
and you won't pay any
tax because if you move into a house and
it's your home residence and then you
fix it up and sell it you won't pay tax
equally if you refinance it you won't
pay tax either so either way you're
pretty good
i wish you all the best thanks so much
for watching this week's q a sunday
next week i'm going to answer your
property investment questions so all you
need to do
comment your questions below i'll do my
best to answer them next week
also wouldn't it be terrible if i answer
your question
but you don't even know i answered it
because you're not subscribed
so subscribe below turn the notification
bell on so you don't miss the video
where i answer your questions
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you